JENNY BROWN: This week, we're
talking about Elastifile,
learning GKE, and BigQuery.
I'm Jenny Brown, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud," where
we serve you the
lowest latency news.
Earlier this year, we launched
Elastifile File Service on GCP,
a fully-managed
version of Elastifile
integrated with Google Cloud.
So what's going to
change with the intent
to acquire Elastifile?
Cloud file storage is set
to become even smarter.
See exactly how
on the Cloud blog.
The demand for running
containerized workloads
in the cloud keeps
growing, and so has
the need for people with
the relevant skills.
With our Architecting with
Google Kubernetes Engine
specialization, you
can gain the skills
to run Kubernetes and deploy
production services on it
using Google Cloud Platform.
Enroll on your journey today.
Last week, we shared
a solution on how
to plan your cloud migration.
Today, we have a new
solution specifically
for migrating to BigQuery from
a data warehouse like Teradata.
This guide includes what to
consider when planning and SQL
references to get you moving.
Read the details
and get migrating.
If you want to see
one more way BigQuery
can help you work
with your data,
check out this blog from
Filipe Hoffa on geolocation.
The sample walks you through
new BigQuery features
and de-identifying IP addresses.
Protecting your data is
now faster and easier
to do than ever.
Thanks for the
breakdown, Felipe.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or even see a full list,
check out the link below.
Have any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the cloud.